part of my journey is I've done a lot of
different things
so my perspective is not just as a
technology CEO or as a serial
entrepreneur whereas a marketer right or
as a sales professional I use all of
those different uh facets of my career
to now create compelling advice insight
and recommendations for companies
because I pull from a lot of different
experiences and people that I've met
really across the globe
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Donald Thompson the CEO
of the diversity movement a
results-oriented data-driven strategic
firm offering clients a productized Dei
Journey built on digital learning tools
expertly curated content conversational
Ai and analytics the company was
recently named to Inc magazines 2021
best in business list in d e and i
advocacy in addition Donald serves as a
board member for several organizations
in marketing Healthcare banking
technology and sports Donald is an
entrepreneur public speaker author
podcaster certified diversity executive
and executive coach he is a thought
leader on goal achievement influencing
company culture and driving exponential
growth he has led companies that
attained successful exits with strong
returns for shareholders and employees
and he writes a leadership column for
WRAL techwire and has contributed to
entrepreneur.com in cnbc.com come
Donald I'm really excited to talk in 20
minutes about your own Journey about
diversity about you as a fraud leader in
the field when you've learned what
you've the different insights that
you've that you've brought in this
domain and how you work with different
organizations
um in different mechanisms so so thank
you again for being here tell me a
little bit about yourself about your
work and the different things that
excited yeah so uh personality I'm the
son of a football coach and American
football is what I would describe and
one of the things that means is that
teamwork is very important to me
um uh competing is very important but
also the ability to get up when you get
knocked down and so that's something
that's built for my Foundation from the
ground up I started my career in the
software space in technology and sales
uh and then runes through the rest of
the ranks and and ended up leading and
exiting a handful of software technology
companies and then moved into being the
CEO of a digital marketing firm and then
have recently spun out and built the
diversity movement to where we're
focused on linking diversity Equity
inclusion to building better businesses
both financially from a cultural
standpoint and then also impacting the
community
now diversity inclusion how you know
obviously this is something that we that
we talk about a lot over the last few
years especially which is fantastic how
did you get how did you get into the
space from a leadership perspective into
a place where you're saying I want to be
I want to move the needle here yeah
that's a great question so when I was
running a marketing agency I had
customers that were asking us how do we
create Multicultural content right how
do we upgrade our website to be more
attractive and authentic to more and
broader groups of individuals how do we
create selling strategies for the lgbtq
uh community and we were happy to do
these things from an optic standpoint
but we also saw that a lot of these
companies were just applying a Band-Aid
approach right just checking the box so
to speak so I asked some of the
companies would you like to think about
diversity Equity inclusion from the
inside out of your organization so that
you're living the messaging that you're
portraying
by and large were absolutely but
we've not run into an organization that
understands our business our brand and
diversity equity and so as an
entrepreneur I was like wait a minute
I've been in the technology space right
I've been in the marketing space right
I've been in a Consulting space right so
I have some business Acumen right I'm an
African-American leader so I understand
some lived experience from diversity
and I understand how to link my actions
to business outcomes right so this might
be an area to where we can make an
impact and so what we each wanted to do
then is create tools and technologies
that folks that we're looking at Dei
could leverage so that diversity Equity
inclusion wasn't just a training seminar
but it was a part fabric of the business
and helped you win in the marketplace
right for example if you're a sales
leader and you have a more diverse sales
team there are numbers that show your
win percentage will be higher what sales
leader doesn't want to higher win
percentage sure if you are looking at
growing your business brand in a
marketing standpoint and now all of a
sudden you've integrated Dei into your
brand strategy and you've expanded the
marketplace for your product now all of
a sudden you have more larger Arenas to
sell into so our goal of the diversity
movement is how do we link Dei to
measurable business this outcome
all right so let's dive into that so we
already made a clear distinction here
that this is not just a training seminar
this is not just information about what
to do this is this is actually digging
into the the specific kpis and you know
of an organization and figuring out how
to make how to say okay yes let's align
incentives let's maximize your winning
right and let's do that through you know
the way that you know the through the
Dei what IDI provides and you'll talk
about that in a second but but the idea
is that let's create an a system of
incentives in which you know we're both
promoting diversity and inclusion but we
do that and from your perspective it's
it's optimizing for winning right that's
right and I think that that's how you
get leadership stakeholders attention
right right
and motivation sure see there's one
thing buy-in well I can buy in as a
leader I can write a check okay go do
something with Dei fantastic
but my engagement as a leader is what
moves the needle for transformation
projects inside any organization whether
you are a 10 person startup 10 000
person or a hundred thousand person
organization the drum beat of the
business is based on the focus and
commitment areas of the CEO and so that
means we had to create diversity Equity
inclusion and transition it to a
language that the c-suite could
understand and that means action and
outcomes right not just Theory and
dialogue
right okay so how how does that actually
work walk me through sort of the process
of you with an organization how does
that actually come about
so let's say you're an organization
let's just use 100 people for sake of a
of a of a size of organization right
you've got 30 to 40 different priorities
but really only three to four of them
can really move the needle at once so
what we do is we tie Dei into already
existing transformational plans of the
organization so if you're launching a
new product then we look at the
marketing and The Branding of that new
product to ensure that you have the
ability to Market that product on a
broader landscape if you're looking to
increase the quality of your leaders in
the organization then we look at the
demographics the schools the different
things that you're recruiting from and
increase the number of applicants
because now you're looking at an
expanded Market if you're looking at
retention for example the data that
we've captured over the last couple of
years working with thousands and
thousands of organizations is very
simple mentoring
sponsorship and career mapping is the
number one lever that you can pull to
retain your high performing people
because most people don't need
organizations they leave managers and
they leave for better career opportunity
but if you have a personalized career
plan with your high performing employee
now the sudden you're going to increase
retention that works across all the
different demographics so again we want
to take diversity Equity inclusion and
focus on the building Better Business
and then when we build better businesses
we want to have outcomes in compliance
for example reduction in lawsuits and
litigation we want to have examples in
increasing sales and revenue we want to
have examples in brand presence which
you can measure an authority of your
brand and so if we keep things to those
things that we can measure it gives time
for those things that take longer in
terms of belonging and feeling in the
organization so that the executives
don't lose motivation to continue
because Dei is a journey but you got to
give people milestones and mile markers
along any Journey right where they get
discouraged
and what incentivizes an organization or
an executive team to come and say okay
now we want to work with Dei in other
words
do they come to you do you go to them is
there an aha moment that that they wake
up and say okay that we need this how
how does one decide to now go on this
journey or this partnership with you all
right so there's a couple levels to that
and it's a wonderful question so one is
the social environment in our country
Dei is a macro level topic right so
Executives say well what are we doing
with Dei right that's kind of the Follow
the Leader type thought process you
could also be crisis driven meaning you
have an incident or something inside
your business right that affects you for
example there was an advertising
campaign by Dove right that portrayed uh
African Americans in a light that was
not very positive and they got a lot of
backlash but they fixed it they worked
on it that's a crisis orientation you
could have a uh gender related issue in
your organization where you have an
employee that is transitioning and
they're not treated well and you have
some litigious issues associated with
that so you could have some chaos
drivers right right but you could also
have some competitive drivers
to where organizations see that if you
expand your recruiting base
if you have a diverse leadership you're
going to be more Innovative you're going
to have a better time to Market you're
going to win more in the marketplace and
that goes back to that winning
percentage of homogeneous sales teams
versus heterogeneous sales teams right
it has the advantages of 70 of people
that are looking for jobs today look at
the Dei footprint of the company before
they sign on with the company
so people are the engine that drives
your Innovation growth is a business
your sustainability then you have to
respond favorably to the things they're
using as a say yes criteria
both as an employee and as a consumer
right tell me a little bit about your
journey you mentioned a little bit of
the Milestones before and let's dive in
a little bit as to your personal journey
and what sort of is your connecting the
dots backwards as Steve Jobs like to say
yeah that's a beautiful way to phrase
the question and you know I think of
myself as a business development either
first and foremost no matter what I'm
doing uh I love creating value for
clients through things that I can
position or Market or sell that's my
gifting and so one of the reasons that
we've been successful in the diversity
movement and growing from zero to 100
clients over the last 12 to 18 months is
because we think about things in terms
of how are we going to help businesses
grow provide massive value and impact
right and the right thing to do should
also equal the right thing for your
business to grow profitably so back to
your question on me and my journey I'm a
sales professional at heart and I love
connecting with people the second thing
that part of my journey is I've done a
lot of different things
so my perspective is not just as a
technology CEO or as a serial
entrepreneur whereas a marketer right or
as a sales professional I use all of
those different uh facets of my career
to now create compelling advice insight
and recommendations for companies
because I pull from a lot of different
experiences and people that I've met
really across the globe throughout my
career
well and if you're looking at your
vision that you're setting for yourself
moving forward
what type of impact do you wish to have
yourself so you know tangibly if you how
are you thinking through the decisions
that you're making you know on a regular
basis what what sort of guides you and
and what is the vision that you are
setting for your own impact yeah thank
you so much one of the things that I'm
continuing to work in but also very
proud is the number of women Executives
that I work with have helped promoted
and leaves and lead the companies that
I've invested in or am on the board of
and so I feel very fortunate with some
of my own privilege in life in having
the opportunity to open some doors
create some opportunities for others
that may have not been seen in the same
way
that's number one the second flame that
I would say in terms of kind of my
career impact is I enjoy the work that I
do as an executive coach a counselor to
business Executives leading an
organization whether it's five people or
50 000 is a lonely place
and so you don't always have someone you
can talk to that's been in the chair
that you're sitting in and so I really
enjoy my time working with Business
Leaders helping them solve tough
problems and being that trusted
Confidant uh that can help them find the
answer I don't have all the answers
but I enjoy the part of my career where
I help Executives find the right answers
for them and for their organization
so from your experience what are some of
the key challenges that you know leaders
are facing when it comes to diversity
and inclusion that you that you help
them overcome because I'm sure there are
some overarching patterns that are
coming about especially for for young
leaders first-time entrepreneurs let's
say like myself that you know we have
these challenges that a lot of others
have faced and there's probably
different schools have thought of how we
can think about them and I'd love to to
leave with the last few minutes
understanding a little bit about what
what we can tangibly do to start
answering these questions or even to
know how to ask them yeah that's a great
great Point
um to say it in a phrase right is
helping CEOs balance empathy and
economics
because the world is asking c-suite
leaders now to not only address the
financial bottom line but really the
triple bottom line which is people right
and profit and that's not something that
is traditionally taught in school that's
not a skill set that's been developed
and so leaders sometimes feel stuck
between those competing standards and so
let me give you some examples of
tangible things you can take away one of
the things I've had to learn as a leader
is how to give and receive feedback we
often over the years talked about the
sandwich method right say something good
say something coaching say something
good when the reality is most people
only hear the negative
so since most people only hear the
negative right then that means we have
to learn how to share the gap between
current performance
and expectation
and partner with the individual on how
to close that Gap so to me not about
just what you describe to the individual
it's what is that business plan that
partnership plan that cohort coaching
plan with that individual to say John
here is a gap between our Revenue today
and where we said we would be
there's some things that you can do but
also as a leader here are a couple
things I can do to bring to the table a
better result we can't lower the
standards but we can chase the standard
together that's different kind of
feedback than you didn't hit your number
if you don't hit your number again
you're going to be on a pip if you're on
a pip for 90 days we're gonna have to
let you go that's very different in
terms of now we're co-owning the
challenge and working on it together the
second thing that I would say is your
organization responds to what you
amplify and your behaviors so leaders
can model inclusive language before they
fully understand all this diasta instead
of saying you guys say everyone
instead of saying man hours when you're
talking about a software development
product say person out
just being more thoughtful in the
language choices we make can start you
on a daily journey to get more
productivity more production more
belonging from the people that you're
sponsor responsible to lead
and so are these things that you
actively work with the leadership team
how how
at what stage do you bring those up
because I'm sure these are kind of
universal things that you'd want to make
sure that all the leaders you work with
they sort of have at least you know I
guess the basics of of you know you're
talking about like language and
vocabulary I mean this sounds like a
pretty fundamental idea that every
leader probably can improve on
regardless of where they're at today
because this is something that's changed
over the last several years
that's exactly right and so to your
point we want to create some small wins
for people in their Dei journey and then
they'll develop momentum for larger
tasks and initiatives sometimes I think
with diversity Equity inclusion we lose
people with uh you know diversity Bingo
and all these words and different things
what really we need to link it to some
critical behaviors that everyone can get
better tomorrow and so number one if you
go to the diversitymovement.com we have
a ton of free resources we're a
for-profit business but our goal is to
have a mission-based business to create
better workplaces so we have over 30
webinars for free we have guides a
calendar on Dei events for free sample
micro videos because
making money is after you build trust
and credibility and show value to people
and so we want to make sure that we
provide high octane education for folks
to get started and then when they're
ready to invest in Dei we are one of the
partners a part of their selection set
but even if we're not we provided them
great value of how they can get started
because we believe that much in how it
helps business our society and our
fellow employees in the trenches
so just to close I guess the thought of
you know making an impact later on is
we're looking at where things are
heading and
you know if we're looking down the line
do you see a Major Impact happening to
organizations in the style of Dei sort
of like the service organizations
although you also have a product which
makes it actually very integrative
is that the way to to really move the
needle here or is it more more so that
things are just going to
change culturally and this is going to
become sort of common knowledge that you
know eventually 20 years down the line
everybody will have how do you see this
playing out here yeah so one of the
things is we try to provide Insight in
the same manner that people learn in
their personal lives so for example most
people are familiar with YouTube most
people might get information from
podcasts most people will get
information through search and through
the internet so we have a library of
over 600 two to three minute video
Snippets where people can learn Dei
topics two to three minutes at a time so
that way they can learn in a familiar
fashion right that they learn new things
on YouTube on Tick Tock right and so our
goal is to provide tools and technology
in the marketplace to make Dei learning
fun informative and time
so
I love it Donald thank you so much for
taking the time to be here and for
sharing these insights and stories with
me I highly highly appreciate it and
appreciate your time and your energy so
thank you very much and best of luck
with Pei with the book and with
everything else you're doing and thank
you again for the time and energy here
uh it was great to be with you and
thanks for the space and time on your
show thank you I appreciate it
[Music]